my name is emma what's your hobby my
hobby is reading oh my god i like to
read too our ideas allow shy or lonely
teenagers to make more friends in real
life i wanna try this new game called
call of duty how do you play this i'm
new and lost at this game why don't you
ask sarah so we created sarah it helps
beginner gamers improve their gameplay
[Music]
it's a very common thing when it comes
to ideation that we're afraid right
afraid of looking silly
i think we try to mitigate some of this
self-censorship so that you can get to
silly ideas which are usually the seed
for more innovative ideas
having a bad idea isn't so bad you can
develop it to like be a very good idea
that people think is very useful
especially in primary school when i have
my own ideas they would usually turn me
down now i feel accepted for my own
ideas using the word complain i think it
actually helped the students to think
about the user problems complaining is
quite a natural thing that humans do
anyway
it tends to be more authentic to what
the problem is about and how to then go
about solving the problem
complaints like he or she doesn't have
any friends but then like constructing
companies like i don't have any friends
but i'll do something about it it's not
like complain it's like a feedback so
during the prototype making process
we gave each other a lot of feedbacks
and remarks on how to improve
students who are shy i find that i have
to help them with questions to bring up
their ideas the most natural is to kind
of just go to the same level as them and
to kind of provide that support and say
that's okay we're here to answer your
questions and help guide you along
we wanted them to actually think about
empathy and creativity and to feel free
to create in a very non-judgmental space
interacting with the designers that
stuck who are real-life practitioners
they'll be able to bounce off ideas and
help our students to build creative
confidence
[Music]
the students have to come up with the
skit to pitch their ideas so i think i
would probably hope to bring to my own
teaching subject
i was pleasantly surprised with the
prototypes that they created and it was
very exciting for us to look at the
pictures yeah 13 thirteen-year-olds can
you know make such creative things with
their hands
all those mistakes that we did right it
still are not pretty well actually
because we learn from like our mistake
then you try something better
i learned more about teamwork if you
don't have any teamwork it will be chaos
doing this program i think i've worked
well with my partners
if you
can listen to other people's opinions
they might also try to listen to your
opinion and mix the combination together
what makes this program very memorable
is like creating the ideas itself it
also like allow us to open our imaginary
minds
[Music]
you